Suicide is one of the hardest things to deal with. Not just for the person considering suicide, but for the People surrounding that Individual
Often, people who observe
suicidal behavior from someone they love become very concerned and even disturbed at what they're seeing. But it's very
Important not to let your shock overwhelm you
Instead of focusing on the sadness of the situation, there are many things you could do to help these suicidal Individuals
1 : don't ask too many questions
In 2010 a study, was done on the rising suicide rates in Japan. An area which has a massive problem with people taking their own Lives
It found that asking too many questions can sometimes cause a negative reaction in suicidal people.
Could this just
be due to japanese culture or is this an indicative of a more widespread treat when it comes to suicide People all over the World
It would make sense for this to apply to all people because the feeling of being interrogated with many, questions is never fun.
Because the shock of finding out someone is suicidal
It can be tempting to bombard them with constant questions. But a more effective technique is to start slow.
Just letting the person know you're there to help efforts
2 : Don't give them false hope.
Another very interesting study
was done in India. Another Country that is suffering from increased suicide rates.
They found that giving the person false hope can be a disastrous decision.
Although you might feel that making unreasonable promises to the person might convince them not to commit suicide. It actually causes the opposite effect
They immediately see through this fake promise and become even more disillusioned with the world they live in
Although it might be tempting to say things like "Everything is going to be okay" take a second to think what you're saying.
Is everything really going to be okay ? As the study suggests, A better option might be to employ a more realistic approach.
3 : Don't try to relate
The same study as mentioned before, also found that trying to relate to the suicidal person can
be a bad decision. You have to understand that in the minds of Suicidal People
no one understands what they're going through
Even if you have contemplated suicide in the past and feel like you've gone through the exact same thing,
don't try to relate your own experiences to what they're going through.
Suicidal person will most likely reject this advice because they believe it does not apply to them.
Instead, focus on trying to listen to them, and trying to understand their own unique circumstances as best you can.
4 : Use their own belief system to convince them. The same study as previously mentioned provides one more great piece of advice.
Researchers revealed that you can help Suicidal People
Choose Life by learning about their personal beliefs and using them to convince the person not to commit suicide if they believe in a specific
Religion
Use teachings from that Religion to convince them about the value of life. If they believe in nothing at all
You can use that to convince them as, well by saying things like "You only live once. Why not make the most out of it?"
5 : Encourage Them to See a professional
One of the best thing to do if not the best thing to do to help
Suicidal People is to encourage them to see a mental health Professional
That's not to say you should refuse to help them telling them to get help and walk away
That would not go down well.
What you can do - is let them know that you're there for them. Listen carefully and then encourage them to get help.
You have to remember that you're not a professional, you're not trained in this and you don't have the resources to help.
Unless of course you are a trained mental health Professional
6 Take them seriously.  There has been A huge tendency to dismiss the validity of suicidal tendencies throughout the years
People often say things like: "They're just doing it for attention." or "You'll never actually go through with it."
This is perhaps the worse outlook you could take when it comes to suicidal people
You have to take them seriously if no one pays attention to them or displays any concern, this might actually push them further towards suicide
It makes them feel alone?
Studies have shown that the vast majority of people who have committed suicides, displayed warning signs before taking their own lives
In addition a study in Finland found that 10% of people who committed suicide
Saw a health Professional within 24 hours of taking their own lives
7 : Try not to seem fake
Something that really causes a negative effect when it comes to dealing with people
Contemplating suicide - is when you appear to be fake
As previously mentioned, it's important you take these people seriously, but this doesn't mean turning yourself into something you're not.
Be yourself.
Don't act like a different person all of a sudden just because you found out that someone close to you is contemplating suicide.
They will see you right through your fake demeanor
This might cause a negative effect, creating a sense of increased disillusion in their view of the world around them.
An example of this would be adopting a baby, being almost patronizing
approach to these people
Speaking softly to them as if they were a small child, but there are many other ways you can
appear fake when it comes to interacting with suicidal individuals.
Encouraging participation in culture
Recently Canada, Finland and other countries situated around the Arctic Belt
embarked on an ongoing study to tackle the growing problem with suicide among the people living in the far North.
The vast majority of these people are part of aboriginal groups, such as the Inuit in Canada and the Saami in Finland -
- societies with growing suicide epidemics.
Although this strategy was specifically tailored towards Inuit People, it can be applied to people all over the World.
When they encourage these people to participate in their own culture, such as singing traditional songs
Creating traditional arts and crafts and generally doing things typical to their traditional culture, to reduce the risk of suicide.
Perhaps this helps because the suicidal people feel like they belong to a larger collective, thus their sense of loneliness is lessened.
They suddenly feel like they belong to part of a Community and a culture that has spanned multiple generations behind them
This strategy could definitely be applied to the general population
Traditional culture Is not something we experience on a day-to-day basis, especially if we live in a big city.
Certain countries
also seem devoid of culture these days, especially nations like America and Canada, who are relatively young countries.
They don't have centuries of tradition like many nations in Europe
Would it help if we begin to actively promote our ethnic cultures? The result in Inuit Societies seem to suggest so.
9 : Address unresolved grief
One of the biggest reasons people contemplate suicide is because they're experiencing unresolved grief
Indeed it's one of the biggest warning signs of People who might commit suicide in the future.
These people might say that they're about to see dead Loved Ones again, or that they wish they could see dead Family Members again.
When people can't properly work out the grieving process, they turn to drastic measures, including suicide.
They feel it's the only way out, and the only way
They'll offer see that person again
If you think this might be the route case of their suicidal thoughts, bring it up.
If you encourage them to address it, they might be able to finally come to terms with it and move on.
10: Stop them from taking certain prescription drugs
There is also a huge problem with suicides in the military
specifically the US Army. The rates are so alarming that multiple studies have tried to look
into this problem and figure out how to tackle it.
In 2012 one of them found that one factor contributing to suicidal behavior
was a reliance on certain prescription drugs - specifically opioids. You seen it again and again
TV Commercials that sell these drugs are flipping the disclaimer at the end, which says: "This might result in suicidal thoughts"
While the study was done through the military, it applies to all people
If you know someone who is suicidal and they take certain prescription drugs (most notably opioids), it might be a good
idea to get them to stop or at least bring up the fact that their medication might be the reason they're suicidal
You have any tips that can help suicidal individuals?
Let us know in the comments below.
If You like this video
Be sure to check out our other social media for more content and we'd like to announce that Psych2Go has now opened a Patreon.
Check it out if you want to support our channel and don't forget to subscribe. Thanks for watching!
*sorry if the subtitle section has a mistakes, if you don't mind you can correct them ;)*